welke first of all it's so good to see
you I feel like the last time I saw you
a whole life has happened you know like
there's so much going on right now so
first of all just how you holding up
these days I'm doing great I've taken
this time to like really do some self
help and to really try to dive in
creatively and like do things that I've
been putting on the back burner for a
while I've been like this is the time
right now there's never gonna be a time
where I'm sitting at a moment up the
ability to also gifted us with masks
gloves so scrubs like I think we it came
at the right time too because we're all
just like cooped up at home and I mean
this is probably the longest you've ever
been in one place I feel like you're
always traveling so well has this time
been really precious to you it has been
really precious to me because I feel
like as performers we become very
robotic and we forget to like live life
and even like in some cases I've been
really productive there also been times
where I've been sitting down binge
watching shows sure and that's something
that was a luxury I never got to enjoy
before I didn't have TVs in my house
before so I got TVs and I've been
spending more time talking to family and
friends and I ever have in the past
decade so that's amazing
it's been kind of in a weird way I don't
say it's a blessing because I realized
it's really tragic time for so many
people and for so many reasons
absolutely happened but for me it has
been a really uplifting time for me to
do self reflecting and to to connect
with people that I wasn't connecting
with and I've heard that from a lot of
people so absolutely it is some crazy
times we're living in right now and I
feel like obviously between Cova 19 and
everything that's happening with the
black lives matter movement it's all
happening in June which is typically you
know our Pride Month you know how have
those two events really affected what
pride means to you these days it's it's
affected it so much because I'm a part
of two disenfranchised groups I am gay
I am african-american and so being in
this industry just in general has been
very difficult for me and for a long
time I would try to express to people
when I was going through without trying
to be pessimistic or you use the black
or gay card as people like to say it but
the reason those cars exist is because
they are things that you have to face on
a daily basis and for me this is one of
the pride seasons that I'll never forget
I was supposed to be doing 16 pride
events but I'm so much happier than I'm
able to like March and fight for gay
rights and also fight for trans lives
and for black lives at the same time and
I don't know it's just been really
really uplifting for me because I feel
like I have been able to be a part of
causing positive change I hope to have
children someday and like me marching
and using my voice and my gift in my
platform to speak up for gay rights
trans lives and black lives it's
something that I'm gonna be very proud
of to be able to say to my kids
I helped play a part in making this love
a safer place for you so absolutely we
live in a world that tells so many
people they're not enough I'm here to
tell you that you are talk to me about
this special one of a kind of
performance you have planned for HBO's
new pride hung well they HBO came to me
and told me that they were gonna find a
way to create pride come rain or shine
yeah we did part of it and to kick off
this series and I was so blown away and
so excited and I have dancers here who
were out of work who weren't able to
work during this time period and I was
like this will be an awesome opportunity
to give them a gig where well social
distancing it's just going to be two
dancers and we created masks to go with
their costumes and they brought in a
full production into my living room and
I saw how my living room was transformed
into basically what like a small mini
Polly Pocket arena stage it was really
really cool and I love the fact that
people are being so creative so I'm
doing pieces from my house party world
tour I started performing in the middle
of the night basically and I did a bunch
of numbers with costume changes wig
changes like makeup just everything it
was really cool to be able to do that in
my own living obviously you and I are
chatting on a day
that is really major because the Supreme
Court just ruled protecting LGBT people
in the workplace I just wanted to get a
quick reaction from you over your
thoughts on that it makes me feel great
it's embarrassing that we are just now
getting this approved and that we're
still fighting for these basic human
rights that are supposedly founded on
but it made me feel great to see in the
middle of fried month I got on Facebook
this morning and my entire timeline was
full of rainbow flags flying all over
the world with people celebrating this
because it we it's a human right we
should be protected and who we fall in
love with or who we sleep with when
we're at home should not affect whether
or not we are able to work and able to
feel safe in the workplace and it's it's
really sad that this concept that feels
fairly pre-stored to me is now being
legalized in a massive way but I am so
happy and so grateful that it has
happened I feel like there were in the
middle of a cultural moment that feels
like a turning point where a lot of
people especially young people are kind
of stepping into their activism for the
first time what advice do you have for
those young people your fans are a lot
of them who are really trying to use
their voice for the first time I think
that if you using your voice is genuine
then it's something that everyone should
do don't do it because you're jumping on
the bandwagon because it's new because
you're bored do it do the research do
the work because it's not enough for us
to go out and March if a week from now
two weeks from now everybody back to
their ways everyone needs to realize the
things that they were doing that were so
like whether it was conscious or
subconsciously racist racist taking the
tools that we have learned during this
quarantine during this research time
during these protests and and applying
it to the everyday life and and use
those values and those morals from your
new compass that you perceived during
this time so still upon your offspring
because we have to start this young like
and these kids are so young that they
will be hopefully teaching their
children how how to treat humans with
just like this simple decency and
kindness
whether that be based on race or based
on sexual orientation are based on some
new future reason we find to
discriminate against better because you
they're really good at that yeah I mean
it's so true and I have to say I feel
like your girl Taylor chose a really
good time to finally start using her
voice you know it hasn't been that long
that she really started to take a stance
politically you know how amazing has
been to see her kind of step into that
role and really really use her platform
for good well I've always known that she
felt the way that she felt since I start
became friends with her I was always not
afraid to ask her questions about how
we're at what her stance was and every
time she answered me and always felt
very genuine and very like not hesitant
she didn't choose her words carefully as
if she were trying to say the
politically correct thing she just said
this is how I feel this is just how it
is it's a basic human right it seems
like that is she would almost like if it
were cool and popular to say duh right
now uh like that would that was how easy
her response was and so I'm glad that
she has gotten to a point now where she
is sharing that with the world because I
do think that often times I mean she is
a heterosexual female it was white and
so I I think that a lot of people who
would initially like gravitate towards
her might be people who are very
different political views and very
different views on the world and like
what should happen with the black lives
matter movement or what should happen
with gay rights and I think her being
someone who they feel safe with and who
looks like their next-door neighbor I
think that's part of the appeal of
Taylor Swift is that she is the girl
next door and even though we don't
really live next door to her because
that will probably be like some gigantic
mansion we do like she makes you feel
that way in the second you meet her
she's immediately disarming because she
does feel like the girl next or she is
the girl next door she's sort of her
very amazing but it is it's really
really awesome to see her using her
voice because the sad truth is her being
a white person with blond hair and blue
eyes saying this in this world right now
holds a lot of weight to a lot of people
who feel very differently than she might
and I think that she's changing a lot of
minds and a lot
hearts and a lot of people are she's
playing a huge part in this evolution
that's happening with the world of the
conversations that are happening in the
homes that need to happen I agree
because she obviously loves humans but
she's really standing for human rights
right now and it's amazing to see do you
mind me asking if you guys have been in
touch and like what those conversations
that looked like last couple weeks
especially since after George Floyd's
death we have been in touch and we've
had a couple of conversations and I wish
I remembered what she said because you
know she talks a lot about white
privilege and when you realize that you
happen and that you have to be willing
to do the research she talked to me
about the fact that she read a lot and
watched a lot so that she could educate
herself I think that she understands
that a lot of the reason why people
don't understand or think that this
whole concept of white privilege is of
Memphis because the fact that you are
white and you can choose to not
acknowledge it is a privilege in and of
itself and she lost that and in her own
words explain that to me because
sometimes I want to you know there's a
movie called a time to kill that I love
where and a huge impactful spoiler alert
moment and the in the movie is where a
man says I chose you as a white lawyer
to represent me because even though you
want to be on this team you're not
you're on that team so you need to say
whatever you would say to yourself to
change your own line is what you need to
those people and that's such a powerful
moment and I think that Taylor sang in
to people who look like her who might
have come from a same background or a
same potentially belief system I don't
know what Taylor was raised to believe I
know her parents and I know that they
are like so open and loving with
everyone but sometimes you just don't
know the things you're being
subconsciously taught and I think that
you have to be willing to put down your
own ego and not take it as an attack on
yourself and absolutely open up and say
I have been a recipient of privilege and
this is what I'm going to do to
acknowledge it and then to address it
and to help change the world so that
everyone receives the same equal
treatment
I loved her words about you in the
billboard feature what did it mean to
hear those were read those words from
her and Billy and also just to be on
that cover I know it meant a lot to you
it was honestly the life-changing I
can't say enough about it to see my face
on there and me being my true authentic
self and being you know showing my
feminine side and my masculine side it
was really cool that they allowed that
to happen on Billboard and very
progressive of them in my opinion and it
meant so much to your Billy and I didn't
even know Billy was gonna be in the
article so I'm out I did that he had
such great statements to say and every
time he speaks it's so like empowering
and to read the nice things that Taylor
said it made me feel great because at
the end of the day you can have a
million followers on every platform but
if you know at the core who you are feel
that you're a good person and that
you're doing positive things but the
platform you've been giving to help
change the world for the better then why
do you happen anyway why are you in this
game and that's why I love Taylor so
much because she does use her platform
to uplift people and the fact that she
acknowledges that I've always been
honest with her and always been really
true about how I feel about her I love
that girl so much I can't even express
to you she's just so I get so protective
of her because her heart is so pure and
in this crazy world that we live in
there are very few people that you meet
and after time and time and time and
time again like I just keep saying how
pure her heart is and how how much she
loves and how empathetic she is to
what's going on in the world at all
times and that's very rare to find in a
human being but even more rare to find
in a superstar who has everything at her
disposal and she could use every done
that she has to buy more houses and a
bazillion cars and do things to uplift
herself and she is constantly waking up
every day doing things to uplift other
people that so many things I wish that I
could be the person telling everybody
all her business but she does so many
things to know people that you do that
she would never know one he's doing for
the right reasons but it's just it's a
she is a very rare human being and I'm
honestly blessed to know someone that is
so sweet and we were so blessed when you
guys did you know you need to calm down
I feel like that's such an important and
amazing piece of work and the fact that
you guys shared that together and
made such a statement I mean I have to
see alive like are you good at are there
any plan I'm like other petit plans I
know you guys perform at the VMAs of
course but were there any plans for you
to pop up during lover fests before it
was postponed no there were no plans but
with tail there's like she is she's I
think she's a Sagittarius and infinite
so fits her personality she's so
easygoing we were on the set up you need
to calm down I was like what do you want
me to wear and she's like whatever you
want to wear like not affect the jacket
that I wore it was like so bored just by
the way I'm gonna show it do you have it
there's never a time that I love it
yes this doesn't look like this in the
video but it's just so much custom
beating every single one of these that's
iconic literally resting room and I fell
in love with it it was I think he was
gonna wear and she was like you like it
you wear it it's fine I'll find
something else I never do that on my own
video oh my god but um she makes me want
to be a better person I just gave a kid
the bubble jacket that I wore for the
cover of the I mean for the for the
Billboard article because I just knew
that it would mean so much to him and I
learned that from her yeah there's an
idea that was inspired by the things
that I see Taylor do but be honest
you're gonna keep keep that rope though
you're hold on to that jacket yes in my
shoes I keep Paul's and says are you
ready I'm ready I'm ready at any moment
and that could happen right she'll just
text you be like hey how do you feel
like hopping on stage this week or not
this week it could be tomorrow and she
knows we're always down I hear you're
working on house party 3 what do you
want fans to know about this follow up
about the record well this follow up has
been like my fans are going to
absolutely kill me because it just keeps
taking so long I just want this album to
be very vulnerable and talk about
different things that are happening and
I keep changing songs and changing
lyrics and going into studio but I want
people to it's not a song that I was
like a bunch of like stereotypical pops
and fun like club anthems it's you know
something to say my passion and talking
about love and heart a
and refiling in love and sometimes for
refiling in love with somebody who broke
your heart and as life keeps happening
and evolving I keep being more and more
and more inspired to change things so
it's a work in progress
and obviously so much has happened in
the world even now that has made me be
like okay I got to pump the brakes even
one more time but when I give it to them
I won't this is an album that is for
like my real true fans that didn't all
of me since day one
yeah listen to everything that I do and
I just want it to be a very vulnerable
experience that I feel like I'm sharing
with them they're not songs that are
gonna play in the club but they're there
they mean a lot to me it sounds
important yeah absolutely and you also
can't rush perfection so take your time
take your time wrapping things up here
obviously your performance is happening
for HBO's digital pride hub is happening
on June teens we've been asking
everybody you know what does June teens
mean to you and how do you feel like the
protests have kind of changed the way
we're talking about it Juneteenth right
now to me it just means like freedom and
the legitimate sense and because before
when I used to celebrate Juneteenth and
we would go to black park that's what we
called it in Plainview Texas where I was
from it yeah we would go black Park and
hang out all day and um and to me it
just meant a time of celebrating your
heritage with people who look like you
and celebrating where we came from and
where we're going to know and but now
because pride is such a big part of my
life I feel even more free during the
month of June because I feel finally as
an adult who started out not feeling
free as a black man and not feeling free
as a gay man and now I'm legitimately
and feeling more and more and more free
every year because so many people are
out there fighting for the rights of my
brothers and sisters whether that be
part of the lgbtq+ community or the
african-american community so freedom is
the word that I would say it would fully
encompass what Juneteenth means to me
you